hey youtubers is Charlie so I have a
whole bunch of Darth Vader castle behind
the scenes I'm going to play this video
then I'll explain Star Wars Celebration
and all the big stuff that's happening
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
going to be Star Wars giveaways
happening all through next week there'll
be a bunch of extra Star Wars bonus
videos so check this out and remember
that there's a lot of special darth
vader stuff happening next week so here
we go when we start to come up with the
idea of we're chronic with me vader we
really started to play around with okay
mood and look well did some early
exploration of what Vader's Castle was
and so when this scene came up we
thought well let's resurrect that idea
in doing the research I mean Ralph did a
lot of drawings for Vader's castle but
he really didn't do any interior
my Lord directeth critic has arrived
but what I found particularly
interesting was that Ralph a design is
slowed down red triangle as the symbol
evader and so I really want to evoke
that in the set itself and so as we were
designing the room we try to very subtly
play that and if you look at the
entrance when critic first arrives the
exterior of that meeting room is a
upside-down cone
[Music]
for fans if they are familiar with Vader
symbol they'll see that connection in
there and then likewise when you see the
actual doorway it's in the shape of
Vader's mouth and so the whole idea for
me was to play off the subtleties of
when you're coming to visit Vader you're
literally going inside him it was
interesting when we're talking about how
do we reveal Vader he's so iconic you
can identify him by just the silhouette
itself and so Guerra thought well why
don't we introduce them by seeing a
shadow first because they'll be even
more threatening and what was great was
that we were paying homage to Indiana
Jones when Marion was in the bar you saw
the villains come in and you see the
shadows creep up we thought well would
it be powerful to do a similar thing and
it works really well because even in
silhouette form you immediately know
it's him and if you notice that there's
a circular platform where Vader and
cronic meet and what I like about that
idea is that if you think about it for
Vader to have a confrontation room in
this big open space word you can easily
fall off the edge is very intimidating
so if whoever is coming to visit him is
always under this veil threat that Vader
could force them off the edge you are
not someone near to Kabul director
clinic
now if there is no death stone there
Senate has been informed that killer was
destroyed in a mining disaster yes well
I expect you not to rest until you can
assure the Emperor the Gailen person has
not compromised this weapon in any way
so I'm still in come on
you'll speak to the Emperor about one be
careful not to choke on your aspirations
director are the history that we do in
designing Vader's castle is war all the
rooms and so we decided that the castle
itself was going to be sent around the
back of time that was the most important
thing but we also knew that there was
going to be a meditation chamber he had
to have like a little training area
maybe down below in the catacombs of the
more ancient area the map of Vader's
castle is all taught out and I'm hoping
that we'll have an opportunity to
actually explore it it's always so cool
to listen to what the ILM people are
thinking when they design all these
things the really big thing they didn't
mention in this is that they've already
confirmed that this is moves too far
they were kind of coy about it when the
movie first came out just because I
think they wanted it to be a surprise
like maybe fans will recognize this
particular lava planet that has special
meaning to Darth Vader's history all the
people behind the scenes are saying that
wouldn't it be fun to go back and
revisit that somewhere in the Star Wars
universe so we have all this last Jedi
kylo Ren stuff going on he's such a beta
fanboy it would make sense that if we
revisit this place in the new films it
would be through his character or even
through Luke Skywalker in raised
characters although I'm not expecting
them to go to MU stefarr it just feels
like if there was a really important
significant place in Darth Vader's
history in kylo Ren was doing everything
he could to collect Darth Vader
artifacts don't you feel like he would
have that location on lockdown but like
he says it's built on an older structure
there is a throne room that Ralph
McQuarrie designs it's below levels but
the castle itself is a tuning force for
Darkseid energy it's basically built on
Darkseid lay lives
moussah far as a planet is very powerful
in the dark side of the force but the
other reason that he spends so much time
there is because he is punishing himself
the most demanding Mercurial environment
imaginable
oleh shifting just think about how the
terrain is so uncertain so it's sort of
like the planet is a metaphor for Darth
Vader himself speaking of which the big
surprise
for celebration so let's talk about
celebration stuff the big surprise is
that Hayden Christensen himself is
confirmed he is coming now they didn't
say exactly what he's doing but they
said there might be some surprises like
they were very tongue-in-cheek when they
were talking about it for the 40th
anniversary panel which is on Thursday
so I'll explain the schedule in a second
for the really big panels but Darth
Vader himself is coming he'll probably
appear during the 40th anniversary panel
next Thursday but he might also appear
during the last Jedi panel I'm not
expecting it because it's going to be
most of the main actors for that film in
it there's going to be some Darth Vader
inside the new films I feel like they'd
want to keep that a surprise so they
might be coy about that and if he did
appear in the new film he would probably
be as a force ghost or like you and
McGregor he said a couple really quick
lines that they insert it into Ray's
forged visions that she had when she
touched Anakin Skywalker's a lightsaber
and that was it he was like oh they you
know they had me in for like a couple
minutes then I rode my motorcycle out it
was great so I would just be blown away
if there was anything more than just a
very light touch of Darth Vader inside
the new films because they're slowly
moving past the Skywalker family but the
new films are still of Skywalker saga
that's why everybody's talking about
moving past the Skywalker's with any
future films after episode 9 but here's
a breakdown of the schedule I'm going to
be doing videos for all this there's
going to be so much Star Wars happening
next week so here's just a quick look at
what's going on this is just a small
fraction of the stuff that they're doing
so Thursday is the 40th anniversary
panel there's rumors that they're going
to announce a spin-off film everybody
thinks it's an obi-wan film but just be
prepared for it to be something else
don't be too disappointed but I know we
all wanted the Emperor's doing a panel
Billy Dee Williams is doing a panel that
day then Friday is when gets real
because that's the last Jedi panel I'm
expecting them to do the exact same
thing they did for the force awakens
which means a trailer and a behind the
scenes reel so it's kind of like two
trailers but one is more of like making
of the last Jedi in addition to a
traditional trailer Mark Hamill is doing
a special panel just about Carrie Fisher
Saturday is the Star Wars rebels season
4 panel they're going to show off a
trailer for that then Sunday Mark Hamill
is doing his Luke Skywalker panel so
that's just a small fraction
of the stuff that they're doing there's
going to be so much more but you guys
could just let me know what kinds of
videos you want me to do
I'll post panel videos trailer
breakdowns anything else you guys
request but they'll be way more Star
Wars than I would normally be posting
for obvious reasons it'll be a comic-con
situation so all the links for my social
is at the top of my main page here
here's Twitter Facebook Instagram that's
where I post updates on what videos are
going to happen so throughout the day
I'll just be live tweeting all the Star
Wars stuff so starting Thursday all the
way through Sunday so a lot of you have
requested a video about Hayden
Christensen returning to Star Wars them
using him in the new films about doing
it obi-wan spin-off them
what would the story be if they chose to
do that film so I'll apply to a video
for that in the next couple of days but
remember they'll probably going to
announce what the next spin-off is next
week so we'll find out pretty soon and
there will be Star Wars giveaways going
on in all those Star Wars videos that I
post next week so all you have to do to
enter those be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video right now it's for
the rogue one blu-ray because that just
drops so while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn more about what's going on with
snoke's character and you can click here
for brand new Rick and Morty thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video Mina
key me anything
you
[Music]